Oh
integrated reporting is a very simple
idea it essentially involves combining a
company's annual report which is its
financial information with a voluntary
corporate social responsibility or a
sustainability report combining those
into a single report to show the
relationship between financial and
non-financial performance which I would
define an environmental social and
governance terms it involves providing
more integrated information on the
company's website so it's not simply
about a paper document and it also
involves leveraging a company's website
to provide more detailed information of
interest to particular stakeholders as
well as for improving dialogue and
engagement with shareholders and other
stakeholders so it's as much about
listening as it is about talking the
benefits to integrated reporting I think
are many number one it provides a
coherent consistent and by definition
integrated message to the entire world
so a company isn't saying one thing to
shareholders and another thing to
stakeholders I think having separate
messages in today's day and age is very
difficult yet leads to better clarity on
the part of the company about the
relationships between financial and
non-financial performance companies are
increasingly making the claim that
sustainability is good for business
integrated reporting is an opportunity
for them to provide a more coherent and
specific explanation for why that's the
case yet lowers reputational risk it
improves engagement with shareholders
it's a form of discipline a company that
is producing an integrated report by
definition will need to have more
integrated management of the entire
range of performance variables financial
environmental social and governance it's
interesting to see in the past couple of
years this is really beginning to happen
different industries different countries
independently simultaneously I don't
think these companies could have
possibly known about what each other was
doing so I think integrated reporting is
clearly an idea whose time
come two days ago I got an email I
participate in a LinkedIn discussion
about integrated reporting that turns
out of major Dutch bank called Rabobank
is producing an integrated report for
the first time and I was reading through
the discussion about what they're doing
and I laughed I mean it was like these
words had been lifted out of my book
which couldn't be the case because they
clearly started working on this at least
a year ago and my book only came out a
month ago but the language was eerily
the same and so again I think it's just
you know one more piece of evidence that
integrated reporting is is one of those
ideas whose time has come when I talked
to people about it my colleagues they'll
say what an obvious idea it's a simple
idea and I laugh when I say it it
certainly is but it's only happened now
and I think it's that way with with big
ideas they they seem obvious once
they've been stated and and I think I'm
fortunate to just have for a variety of
reasons been able to notice that this
was happened in the corporate community
and try and capture and codify it to
help spread the word and to help speed
the adoption of integrated reporting
because I think it's absolutely
fundamental for a sustainable society